bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver à la une de ça vous regarde ce
soir le baptême du feu du nouveau
gouvernement dans l'hémicycle jean
castex eric dupond moretti
roselyne bachelot les nouveaux visages
étaient sur le grill dans une ambiance
surchauffée alors que révèle cette
première séance de questions au
gouvernement
sur la forme comme sur le fond on en
débattra ce soir c'est un livre qui l'a
longtemps emporté en lui a mis quatre
ans à l'écrire comment traduire au plus
juste le chaos et l'inconfort du
survivant une minute 49 secondes chez
actes sud rapide de l'intérieur les
attentats de charlie hebdo et c'est le
prix du livre politique 2020 remis
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée sont lauréats
le dessinateur riss nous a accordé un
entretien enfin yves jean castex qd
c'est alex taylor qui nous le dira à la
fin de cette émission dans sa revue de
presse européenne voilà donc pour le
programme c'est parti à ce tag sévère
n'oubliez pas ou mia
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
s'il y en a un que l'on n'attendait pas
dans le registre de l'humilité c'est
bien lui
nous sommes des amoureux du
contradictoire moi j'ai besoin de vous
dans mes nouvelles fonctions
j'ai besoin de vous à la fois pour me
guider et aussi pour la contradiction
que vous apporterez voilà j'ai besoin de
vous laissez-moi à prendre eric dupond
moretti dans ses premiers pas un peu
hésitant il faut l'avouer de garde des
sceaux on va en parler ce soir de ce
baptême du feu de ces baptêmes du feu
parce qu'ils étaient nombreux les
nouveaux ministres à s'essuyer à
l'exercice face aux députés bonsoir
coralie dubost bons sauts merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes député la république
en marche de l'hérault face à vous robin
reda bonsoir et bienvenue député l'est
républicain de l'essonne est bienvenu
avoue pierre jacqmin bonjour merci
d'être là vous êtes le rédacteur en chef
de la revue regards on va les passer au
peigne fin ces images vous étiez pour
vous dans l'hémicycle tout à l'heure
mais d'abord on commence avec le regard
de blacko sur sept séances de bizutage
si j'ai bien compris c'est tout de suite
mon sens madame monsieur bonsoir
stéphane bien si j'ai bien compris les
députés ne les ont pas accès à l'hélice
et s et la séance de bizutage pour le
nouveau gouvernement aujourd'hui savait
que député rêve de devenir ministre donc
ils sont un peu jaloux ils sont remontés
quand ils voient arriver les petits
nouveaux et alors les mystiques le vide
c'est déjà impressionnant mais quand il
ya 577 députés kurdes qui invective qui
vocifèrent fuir le stade vélodrome quand
on reçoit le psg mais ce cas rien là
c'était vraiment une épreuve
traumatisante
alors comment ils s'en sont sortis des
petits nouveaux alors à tout seigneur
tout honneur le le premier ministre
évidemment mais commençons par le
premier ministre alors comment dire bon
bah faut être indulgent
c'était sa première prise de parole il
va certainement s'améliorer mais comment
dire je
comment dire ben quand je parle
vous trouvez un bon orateur si c'est
d'abord ce que l'avantagé avec jean
castex c'est qu'on comprend tout ce
qu'ils sachent quand même première
qualité
mais le problème ce qui farm est très
très très lentement mais c'est en plus
il a la manie de répéter deux fois
détruite dans la phrase donc les propos
les plus simples mais ils peuvent
paraître mais un peu temps interminable
attente race très simple je me l'a dit
j'ai le plus grand respect pour le
parlement et l'assemblée ça m'a pris
quoi 3 4 secondes pour le dire le jean
castex la même phrase c 17 secondes en
écoute sachez sachez que j'ai et que
j'aurai toujours un grand respect pour
le parlement et pour l'assemblée
nationale et pour l'assemblée nationale
effectivement vous voyez le discours de
politique générale normalement ça prend
une heure et demie quand on est parti
pour 6 heures
moi je pense qu'il faut une substance on
suspension de séance au milieu pour vous
chacun puisse se dérouler par orateur
qui veut pour pas forcément quand
orateurs pour jean castex mes eric
dupond moretti alors abba dupond moretti
c'est la grande déception du jour là
franchement moretti éloquence un câlin
en disant on va voir ce qu'on va voir
mais pas du tout moretti mais pas du
tout il faut dire que la grande
différence quand même entre s'exprimait
devant les députés rassemblés et devant
un très bien lire au tribunal quand mort
et il part dans une grande envolée
ben le moindre bruit dans la salle le
moindre gars qui hurleraient aux fondus
dans le public
le président évidemment il évacue
immédiatement l'aca il suspend la séance
quand on est au tribunal quand on est à
l'assemblée ben c'est pas pareil
j'aimerais que vous me laissiez au moins
m'exprimer au pardonnez moi on ne juge
on ne les messieurs le député je
voudrais vous répondre complètement je
je je vais vous rép
et est ce qu on décompte les
interventions des combats à ben voilà on
souffre en silence
voyez le bizutage même richard ferrand
et bisous de richard ferrand alors les
autres les autres petits nouveaux comme
ensemble elles sont mieux tirées donc
par exemple barbares bon pili donc faut
reconnaître qu on a vu tout de suite la
différence c'est une politique elle est
à l'aise connaît très très bien
l'assemblée elle a déjà été membre d'un
gouvernement
je vais vous dire en la voyant que
j'avais appris que c'était un peu la
star du nouveau gouvernement notamment
parce que il a semblé que c'était comme
des actrices qui venait recevoir un prix
saoudi des césar les membres de l'action
après très ému passant par om mu ému
merci à faire dans les dix premières
secondes les 10,5 fois merci un merci
toutes les deux secondes canard
merci merci et puis alors là où c'était
vraiment la même chose qu'au césar c'est
que très important quand on reçoit un
césar remercier toute l'équipe du film
sans oublier ni même un second rôle et
même un technicien et ben voila barbara
pompidou elle remercie toute l'équipe du
film
on l'écouté je vais avoir avec moi
évidemment elisabeth borne à qui je
succède et que je remercie tellement
pour son travail
je vais avoir avec moi bruno le maire
pour la relance économique
je vais avoir avec moi julien de
normandie sur l'agriculture je vais
avoir avec moi évidemment au sein du
ministère emmanuelle wargon et jean
baptiste djebbari sur nos logements sur
le transport sur les outre-mer
évidemment je vais avoir sébastien
lecornu sur la mère annick girardin
voilà du jardin cité lui arrive on parle
jamais le mot d'habitude pourquoi et
l'outre-mer monde barbare à
l'environnement va avoir besoin de tout
le monde elle sera peut-être un peu plus
isolé
d'ici quelques semaines on sent bien
qu'elle a déjà fait de la politique un
barbara pompidou comment ça s'est passé
pour elisabeth moreno pour elle c'est
tout nouveau
alors me disent à la diversité s'est
passé en deux temps - la première fois
quand et s exprimer je me suis dit ouh
là est-ce qu'on va pas une erreur de
casting parce qu'elle avait un petit
côté midinette
on en est là présent connaît pas la
bonne attitude escalader prendre un self
y est ce qu'on ait demandé un autographe
à quelqu'un écoute et on s'est demandé
un franchement j'ai l'habitude de vous
regarder à la télévision et être ici
avec vous ça me paraît totalement
surnaturel vous n'êtes plus beau en vrai
bon ça c'était sa première action en
fait c'est très vite passé parce qu'elle
a répondu la question que posait une
députée socialiste qui lui disaient mais
qui lui reprochait de dire d'ailleurs
quand on est une femme et comment dans
la hiérarchie on est moins exposé au
sexisme
alors la réponse et lisbeth moreno bah
écoutez écoutez la mais l'été très nette
ce que je suis une femme parce que je
suis une mère parce que j'ai grandi dans
une cité
quand je vous dis que l'émancipation
économique est la base pour sortir de la
misère et de la pauvreté et pourraient
être considérées c'est une vérité et on
a baissé les applaudissements l'as
manning à des jeunes et même
l'approbation la députée socialiste qu'à
la fin il y avait d'accord ça c'est de
la réponse bon voilà riaïna qui était
inattendu et qui se sont révélés bons
d'autres qu'on attendait qu'ils ont un
peu déçu par le plus vite ça c'est
important qu'ils parlent plus vite un
petit peu plus vite je suis sûr qu'il
vous écoute ce soir stéphane merci
peut-être avant de rentrer dans le
détail parler quand même du premier
ministre puisque c'est vraiment voilà le
pilote de cette nouvelle équipe romareda
quand on est un jeune député comme vous
dans l'opposition et qu'on sait que ça
va être compliqué c'est un baptême du
feu
on me dit quoi je vais pas les rater je
vais je vais quoi hurler les noms
d'oiseaux ou au contraire si je regarde
peut-être qu'un jour je serai à leur
place d'abord on a beaucoup parlé de la
forme et c'est normal parce qu'il faut
bien que vos téléspectateurs comprennent
que le gouvernement est obligé à cette
séance de questions au gouvernement
c'est la constitution qui l'y oblige et
en fait le gouvernement n'avait rien à
dire aujourd'hui puisqu'il n'y a eu ni
la feuille de route premier spa emmanuel
macron le 14 juillet ni le discours de
politique générale du premier ministre
qui doit être l'acte fondateur qui
ensuite permettra de répondre aux
questions
je comprends c'était pas pour excuser le
manque de fond peut-être que jean castex
admise dans ses réponses cet après midi
mais je comprends qu'ils devaient broder
autour pour l'installation est ce qui
vient de votre famille politique je ne
connaissais de vue dans ma famille
politique je suis pas particulièrement
un proche de jean castex je sais qu'il
est n'a pas d'application très difficile
elle est interrogée par le dit vous êtes
de gauche est question je sais que nous
avons une identité politique commune
avec jean castex je sais que beaucoup de
membres de ma famille politique et des
membres du groupe l'est républicain le
respecte et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
en tout cas mon attitude ça n'est pas à
celles de l'opposition systématique
c'est celle de de soutenir les skhira
dans le bon sens lorsque nous aurons la
feuille de route et lorsque nous
stéphane le débit assez lent ça va être
un vrai sujet ou pas je crois qu on a
été tous un peu surpris par le rythme de
réponse de jean castex avec la part de
banques de sons que je viens d'évoquer
parce qu'il n'avait pas grand chose à
dire il ne pouvait pas dévoiler une
feuille de route que le président de la
république s'est réservé à lui même
ensuite moi pour tout vous dire j'ai vu
jean castex sur le terrain gelé vue pas
plus tard que samedi il avait réservé sa
première visite à mon département de
l'essonne je les trouvais beaucoup plus
rapide et au club beaucoup plus à l'aise
sur le sur le terrain impressionnés
paradis va les défendre votre nouveau
premier ministre j'en suis certaine mais
on va écouter quand même jean luc
mélenchon parce que au fond s'il y en a
un dans l'opposition qui a démonté jean
castex et lui c'était assez pénible à
supporter quoi parce que
les mots plus entre les arbres et les
arbres entre les mots 1 donc il est là
il parle à deux à l'heure pour dire des
banalités
alors soit on le prend mal et on dit
mais il se moque de nous soit on se dit
bah c'est le maximum dont il est capable
donc c'est vraiment c'est pas un beau
moment de démocratie parlementaire ça
c'est sûr c'est pas un grand moment
d'abord avec un tout petit peu d'humour
je voudrais dire à jean luc mélenchon
qu'à chaque fois qu'un arbre pousse est
une bonne nouvelle pour la transition
écologique et qu'il faut se garder de ce
type de commentaire pour la suite des
perles dans cet exercice devrait alors
il ya deux choses moi je pense qu'on a
des réponses de fond sur des questions
de fond est que quand on a des questions
fort mais qu' il ya des questions qui
sont là juste pour tester les nouveaux
entrants vous avez des réponses en forme
de test aussi la seconde chose sur le
rythme mois il se trouve alors je suis
d'une autre génération que quand ma
famille me regarde et je pense notamment
mes parents
les remarques immédiate qui m'ont été
faites sur les premiers plateaux
télévisés ou mes premières interventions
d'hémicycle ça a été de dire lesquels
des big par alfi tu ralentis et je pense
que entre le rythme que l'on souhaite
avoir en séance parce qu'on connaît ses
idées parce que l'on sait où on va parce
qu'on a beaucoup de choses à dire et que
quand même dire beaucoup de choses en
deux minutes c'est très court de minutes
on se rend pas compte et donc
effectivement le débit est d'ordinaire
très rapide mais pour autant moi il me
semble que quand on s'adresse à
l'ensemble des concitoyens qui ont pas
forcément tous les éléments de tous les
dossiers comme nous ne pouvons aller
travailler au quotidien
c'est plutôt une bonne chose que de
prendre le temps et de marquer aussi la
ponctuation c'est un respect de la
langue française donc j'ai pas de
difficultés particulières là-dessus
sergeac main sur la forme vous l'avez
vous l'avez entendu les commentaires au
début c'était le président emmanuel
macron a dissout matignon en nommant
jean castex c'était c'est un exécutant
il est transparent sa techno et c
on peut pas dire ça totalement
aujourd'hui quand même j'avais assez peu
de sympathie politique pour l'ancien
premier ministre mais j'ai peur qu'il
nous manque a tous beaucoup mais on va
apprendre à connaître le style jean
castex aujourd'hui c'était l'épreuve de
feu vous le dit c'est le titre je crois
émission on va apprendre à le connaître
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on va on va
s'attarder à parler de la forme parce
que sur le fond finalement effectivement
il avait rien à dire la feuille de route
n'est pas encore totalement connues en
tout cas part nous grand public et que
donc du coup il ne pouvait effectivement
qui émergeait à peine il a parlé il
aurait pu répondre mais c'est son jeu
c'est vrai que j'allais dire l'un peut
aussi je reproche à lyon la protéger
quand reproché à certains députés
d'avoir posé des questions qui étaient
pas franchement sur le fond libre au dip
au ministre de répondre euh juste eu
mention du fond et c'est pas été
vraiment la démonstration pour le
parlement au fond de devoir attendre
l'interview présidentielle avant le
discours de politique générale ce qui
fait qu'avec ces questions on était
effectivement pour dernier un exercice
purement formelle non mais après je
pense qu'il faut pas se leurrer non plus
on attend un discours de politique
générale pour avoir une feuille de route
globale du gouvernement mais on a quand
même des ministres avec un portefeuille
et une feuille de route vous devenez pas
ce serait quand même surréaliste en
france au 21ème siècle que vous deveniez
ministre sans feuille de route dans
chacun des discours de passation que
vous avez eu les grands projets qui ont
été tracées on les connaît il n'ya pas
d'illusions sur ce sujet après sur la
forme je reprends pour dupont moretti
le pauvre occupant un petit peu quand
même du milieu judiciaire et connaissant
un tout petit peu les prétoires même si
je ne suis pas madame avocate me semble
que l'exercice est très différent et
qu'il est tout à fait normal les
premiers temps de s'adapter de
s'acclimater
c'est quand même pas naturel de
s'exprimer devant effectivement 600
personnes qui hurlent et qui trouve ça
parfaitement normal de faire le cirque
et de taper bon je regarde les avis sont
partagés on protège un peu aussi le
premier ministre la vraie question qu'on
a posés moi je pense qu'il rêve ou trois
fois c'est sur le pourquoi on ne retire
pas le système des retraites alors que
enfin la réforme pardon des retraites
alors que toutes les organisations
syndicales demandent s'il se présente
comme étant un mec de dialogue un mec
qu'ils vont entendre les délégués et il
répond j'aime à cette question la
question et mis sous le tapis donc il y
avait une occasion faire de la politique
avec vous pour moi il a répondu à la
question puisqu'il vous ai dit remettre
la réforme des retraites sur l'établi
dans le dialogue c'est à dire que vous
reprenez le périmètre de la réforme
il a dit que ce qui était non non non
négociable c'était la partie système
universel pour remettre les gens au
niveau enfin je le rappelle on a quand
même 42% des cartes de pension de
retraite entre les femmes et les hommes
vous devrez traité qui vont en situation
de précarité pour avoir des mines
manon néo zélandaise items plus chez les
partenaires sociaux nos yeux sur même là
il a précisé que sur le reste il y avait
effectivement une nouvelle période de
concertation et de dialogue qui s'ouvre
et moi je trouve ça intéressant je pense
que on n'est pas obligé d'être dans la
radicalité oui/non noir blanc on peut
juste regarder leurs projets jacquelin
sur la méthode de la concertation il a
dit qu'il serait le premier ministre du
dialogue le répète c'est vrai qu'il a la
personnalité d'un homme de dialogue et
c'est un haut fonctionnaire qui a eu
l'occasion de discuter avec des élus de
droite de gauche et beaucoup apparemment
en tout cas lui reconnaissent que ce
soit des élus de gauche et d une droite
cette facilité de la discussion de la
négociation de la concertation il a
cette image là on va voir si
effectivement la négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux va pouvoir s'engager
mais je parle bien de négociation c'est
à dire que on nous a vendu effectivement
tout au début de ce quinquennat qui a lu
énormément de concertation de
consultation des partenaires sociaux sur
tous les sujets et que c'est scandaleux
qu'aujourd'hui les syndicats ne soient
pas autour de la table sur un certain
nombre de sujets et ne veuille pas même
intégrer le tour de table mais pourquoi
mais parce que ils sont là normalement
ils sont présents mais ils sont entendus
certes non ils sont pas entendus
d'ailleurs ils sont écoutés ils sont pas
entendus et c'est bien le problème
donc la tâche de monsieur castex avait
aussi d'essayer de dégager des compromis
avec les partenaires sociaux
et c'est ça qui qu'on appelle le
dialogue social notre pays et ils
essaient fondée sur le dialogue social
et fort franchement on n'a pas vu depuis
le début de ce quinquennat une volonté
de discuter avec les partenaires sociaux
de discuter avec les élus locaux de
discuter avec les associations et ça va
être un peu un des enjeux et je sais
c'est vrai qu'il a sept personnalités là
il faut qu'ils en fassent la
démonstration mais il faut aussi qu'ils
fassent la démonstration que la
négociation est possible qu'il ya de la
matière à négocier on va attendre de
savoir ce qui ressortira pas de ces
négociations il faut rappeler que les
partenaires sociaux dans leur ensemble
un de la cfdt en passant par le medef
puisque c'est l'aider les deux seuls qui
était en discussion ne souhaite pas
remettre sur le métier cette réforme des
retraites je vous ramène à la forme
parce que pour cette senio log que vous
allez entendre au contraire jean castex
est un grand tribun seul le premier
ministre à la parole vous l'écoutez
merci merci monsieur le président il a
réussi à s'imposer d'emblée c'est pas
quelqu'un qui est dans un rapport de
séduction c'est quelqu'un qui est dans
un rapport de pédagogie il bouge
beaucoup
ils n'arrêtent pas de parcourir
l'auditoire la tête à gauche la tête à
droite
comme si il voulait s'adresser à chacun
en particulier un plan de relance
ambitieux c'est un homme qui se présente
comme un homme de terrain en fait
d'abord parce qu'il ya un terroir
derrière son accent et qui parlent fort
comme quelqu un député qui se déplace ou
moins ministre qui va rencontrer des
gens et qui prend la parole comme c'est
un peu un foutu à l'extérieur abla
députés madame la députée une crise une
crise
j'ai l'honneur j'ai l'honneur il a une
diction très clair c'est comme s'ils
scandaient un petit peu comme un
comédien qui qui qui se rendraient un
discours il veut presque rendre des
comptes dire c'est exactement ce qu'il
va faire il apparaît comme quelqu'un
décide décidé et qui emploie tous les
moyens pour faire passer son message
c'est une il parle comme un tribun un
vrai truc en voilà des propos recueillis
par nathalie guillois l'ancrage local
ce que dit cette linguiste sémiologue
romareda il parle du terrain c'est vrai
que c'est ça peut être un peu ce qui
manquait à cette équipe quelqu'un qui
puisse dire moi tu attrapes
pardonnez-moi prades alors dans les
pyrénées ont dit pas pradet x 210 prades
on ne parle pas de ça ça me ça me
revient pas au contraire moi à prades
on me parle de ça ça ça manquait oui
vous faites ce sentiment des connexions
même si le précédent premier ministre
était également un élu local peut-être
qu'il n'avait pas su en donner toutes
les dimensions et surtout pas su nouer
avec le président de la république une
relation qui lui permettent de mettre en
avant l'importance des territoires les
questions au gouvernement c'est un
exercice dynamique
donc c'est un exercice où même si le
premier ministre peut déborder du fameux
temps de parole limité à 2 minutes pour
les parlementaires ou pour les ministres
il est de coutume que le premier
ministre ne fasse pas un discours
solennel à ce moment là et donc il peut
effectivement amener des anecdotes
s'appuyer sur son expérience
mais il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le ton
qu'a adoptée jean castex était plus son
os soit de politique générale soit d'un
grand discours est on a trouvé je dis
pas qui me l'a dit mais c'est quelqu'un
sur le plateau qu'il parlait un peu
comme ils font la dictée et qui parle
très lentement très lentement pour que
tout le monde est bien le temps
d'entendre et de venir
mais si on revient en arrière il ya une
épreuve du feu c'est effectivement
l'hémicycle mais il ya une autre épreuve
c'est celle de l'interview de jean
jacques bourdin
quand on repense à la manière dont
edouard philippe avait au fond essayer
de réussir l'exercice on se dit tiens
tiens et bien la comparaison est plutôt
favorable à jean castex regarder pour
mémoire je suis d'abord sachez le on ne
se connaît pas un homme libre un homme
libre je suis devant vous premier
ministre du président même grand dans un
gouvernement d'unité et de cohésion avec
une seule préoccupation
une seule l'action l'action la crise qui
arrive mais comprenait aucune feuille
devant moi je n'ai pas tous les chiffres
en tête je ne suis pas un surhomme
j'ai pas tous les chiffres en tête moi
je suis un gars sérieux
j'essaie de faire les choses
sérieusement quand je sais je dis quand
je sais pas je t'ai vaut mieux c'est
mieux voilà de skill complètement
différents mais il faut expliquer que
voilà c'est à chaque fois
première interview un peu musclée en
longueur jean jacques bourdin les
premiers ministres s'il dit je castex
mais ce sont deux styles
incontestablement différent et il n'y a
pas à dire un style est plus favorable
que l'autre moi j'apprécie les deux
styles sont différents on a eu un style
pendant trois ans nous en avons un autre
et ça me semble très intéressant aussi
que la république puisse bénéficier de
compétences différentes parle beaucoup
du style parce que sur la politique on
sent bien que le cap est le même c'est
un changement dans la continuité
ça fait quarante huit heures ça fait 48
heures je pense que il va pas s'emballer
on va leur laisser un peu plus d'une
semaine
je voulais revenir sur un point sur le
caractère d'élu local c'est vrai que
d'or philippe l'était aussi simplement
prades c'est une plus petite ville et je
pense que ça c'est véritablement une
différence moi sur ma circonscription
j'ai trente deux communes le maire de
montpellier
il n'a absolument pas le même rapport
aux montpelliérains que le maire de
gallargues avec beaucoup moins
d'habitants où le maire de castelnau où
le maire de l'une des autres et par son
âge il faut parler lentement fois par
l'effort vous connaissez tous le monde
vous connaissez presque tout le monde
vous connaissez tous vos commerçants
vous les voyez tous les jours rires
jacques soit exact qu est ce qu il
cherche le français dans les grandes
villes où on incarne castex parce qu'on
les sent plus sur le positionnement
politique c'est vraiment bonnet blanc
blanc bonnet vous avez vous avez raison
interrogé lyle le losc a voulu faire la
démonstration qu a sans doute voulu
faire le président de la république
parce que quand jean-luc mélenchon dit
qu' il n'y a pas un bon moment
démocratie dans un moment où il devrait
effectivement y avoir mon démocratie
c'est que on a tous en tête des images
enflammé de grands débats de grands
discours nourri de conviction c'est ça
aussi qui fait un homme ou une femme
politique c'est les convictions qui
porte qui font porter la voix haute on
l'a vu avec christiane taubira on va
avec jean luc mélenchon
on l'a vu avec jeux eux-mêmes philippe
seguin cd il parle
les convictions chevillées au corps et
c'est ça qui manque aussi sans doute
c'est dans l'âme acronis et qu' il ça
manque de personnalité politique qui
incarne et c'est pas pour rien qu'ils
aient choisi
roselyne bachelot à la culture et un
dupond moretti même si nous a un peu
déçus cet après midi mais je suis sûr
qu'ils nous décevra pas l'incarnation et
c'était très intéressant parce que là
c'est mieux que vous avez interviewé a
dit il n'a pas fait le choix de la
séduction or la politique c'est
précisément ça c'est aussi l'art de la
séduction c'est l'art du contradictoire
comme l'a dit dupont moretti cet après
midi mais c'est aussi l'art de la
séduction ça veut dire qu'il faut aussi
avoir ses convictions sa manière de dire
les choses et sa manière de faire de la
politique
et c'est sans doute ce que n'a pas
réussi à faire emmanuel macron avec son
mouvement en marche c'est faire incarner
une génération de gens qui ont des
convictions chevillées au corps et qu'il
incarne à travers un discours qui a
inscrit justement de ce qu'on avance
convictions et qu'on est qu'on passe à
eric dupond-moretti peut-être avant cela
pour refermer cette page décryptage si
l'on peut dire sur jean castex ruiz jean
castex
c'est alex taylor qui va nous le dire
comment la presse européenne
alex a réagi
à la nomination du nouveau premier
ministre français et au nouveau
gouvernement
bonjour mais rihanna en gros elle
essayait de répondre à la question du
new york times ou et jean castex une
technocrate à l'oral sans expérience
c'est le verdict el país en espagne il
ya des élus justin qui passent des
années a comploté pour accéder au
pouvoir multiplie les prestations de
télé distribuant des croche-pieds aux
concurrents et des salamalecs au tout
puissant
d'autres comme castex passent leur
carrière loin des tumultes puis du jour
au lendemain se retrouve propulsé aux
commandes la repubblica en italie parle
du centre de gravité qui en france à
basculer vers le centre droit
notons passage la seule vraie surprise
la nomination d'une médiatrice timo et
controverses aux avocats et rock
je cite dupond moretti puis en allemagne
le frankfurter allgemeine zeitung est
également un peu déçu sur souvent déçu
cette fois ci car jean castex n'a
nullement qu'ils soient des macros de
changer en permanence et secrétaire
d'état chargée de la politique
européenne
surtout au moment de la présidence
allemande de l'union européenne et les
journaux britanniques alex est ce qu'ils
sont plus tendres c'est que je n'ai pas
osé à gauche the guardian est un poil
déçu macron avait promis de nouveaux
talons et de nouveaux visages ou
sont-ils de temps et se demande si
l'accent de twain du sud-ouest suffira à
jean castex pour séduire un électorat
déjà mis à rude épreuve
mais pour finir on peut toujours compter
pour quelques vacheries sur de telegraaf
qui réserve sa rare tendresse uniquement
à son ex propre chroniqueur un certain
boris johnson et qui titre que mc ren
est critiqué pour avoir nommé au poste
pm un homme enti littéralement une
personne non existante ou une nullité
mais un autre mon dictionnaire qui est
peut-être un peu vache
le dictionnaire dans sa traduction
j'entends en ce qui concerne le verdict
même on verra par la suite
je vous le confirme ses vaches merci
beaucoup avec moi passer maintenant
jean castex n'est pas que les anglais
s'en moque soit c'est ça la différence
en vallée du bouès ses vaches et c'est
faux c'est à dire qu'au delà d'avoir été
et d'être élues locales
il a aussi été élu départemental en
intercours secrétaire général adjoint de
l'elysée dans sa conférence de l'est
bien nombreux mis la naissance de
l'ensemble des ces règles les canaris
sont précisément intéressant de pouvoir
avoir cette vision hyper rural
territoriale est hyper macro secrétaire
général adjoint de l'elysée fin excusez
moi pas grand monde à cette expérience
là on n'est pas connu du grand public il
n'est pas connu non plus de votre
famille patients et lumière et il est
nommé il n'est pas élu il est nommé
premier ministre et que ça peut aussi
poser des questions en termes
démocratique de voir nommer quelqu'un
que personne ne connait on ne sait pas
d'ailleurs vous interroger la
constitution sur la nominer rend pas
forcément à l'excution l'avancé seront
envisage vous montrer et on a vu tout à
l'heure celui d'eric dupond-moretti
robin reda pourquoi vous l'avez mal
accueillie alors c'est vrai qu'on était
on était un peu ce qu'on s'attendait aux
ténors du barreau et moi on n'est pas
sûrs au nez pourquoi les bancs de la
droite donc chahuté à ce point à titre
personnel moi je l ai écouté j'étais
très curieux comme d'autres de savoir ce
qu avec dupont moretti allait nous
réserver comme première intervention
cela dit je comprends parce que il faut
qu eric dupond-moretti comme d'ailleurs
les autres nouveaux membres du
gouvernement comprenne que le
gouvernement est responsable devant le
parlement et que l'irrévérence l'un
discipline parfois ça fait partie du jeu
parlementaire services it et ce tweet
d'une politologue guy morin qui écrit je
crains que la condescendance le mépris
les moqueries que les parlementaires ont
réservé à à dupont moretti lors de ses
premières questions au gouvernement ne
donne pas du tout une image glorieuse du
parlement ça le rend au contraire
sympathique
on a tous eu à un moment un autre a
critiqué le fameux cirque donc au rallye
du boss parlais tout à l'heure je le
redis l'irrévérence ça fait partie du
parlement parce que le parlement c'est
le peuple et que le gouvernement est
responsable de
le parlement c'est nous qui avons
autorités quelque part sur les ministres
et qu'il ya deux jours je me dis à
chaque fois mauvaise impression et
donnez vous à vociférer hurler comme des
supporters
eric dupond moretti qu'il y a de joie
était un chef d'entreprise qui n'avait
de comptes à rendre qu'à ses clients et
qui n'était contrôlé par personne
aujourd'hui se retrouvent ministre de la
république sous le feu des critiques des
observations pour le moment il n'a rien
mis en oeuvre c'est compliqué de
critiquer ça vous allez poser sur votre
nouvelle bête noire à droite
non parce que je pense que eric dupond
moretti est quelqu'un de respecté
quelqu'un d'admirer parfois quelqu'un de
qui fait polémique aussi mais par ses
prises de positions d'avocats et est
maintenant ce qu'on demande à voir ses
prises de position deux ministres et
comme il a dit d'homme libre libéré des
contraintes de s'éclairer d'attenté
d'enfermer dupond-moretti sous les
chênes chef d'entreprise d'un avocat
quand même qui a une éthique et une
déontologie et son ordre
il rendait des comptes aussi ils
pouvaient devoir rendre des comptes à
son ordre sur le cirque dans l'hémicycle
je voudrais le dire en toute humilité ça
peut être surprenant les premières fois
mais finalement quand vous y êtes quand
vous siégez si on est si on est intègre
et je pense que ces trans partisan alors
parfois effectivement c'est sûr jouer
largement sur jouer on pourrait s'en
passer
mais parfois les sujets que vous êtes en
train de débattre il vous emporte
précisément parce que vous êtes plein de
conviction précisément parce que vous
avez des choses à dire et que quand vous
êtes six ans dans un hémicycle vous ne
pouvez pas avoir la parole à chaque fois
que vous avez quelque chose à dire
pourtant vous avez des choses à défendre
et parfois ça ressort ça vous ça vous
dépasse ça vous surprend
et ça s'exprime c'est déroutant par la
manière mais il a abordé la question il
a joué profil bas très clairement
aujourd'hui eric dupond-moretti bien sûr
mais je pense que vous a surpris ou pas
non parce que je pense que c'est un
homme intelligent
je pense que c'est un homme intelligent
talentueux et qu'il a l'intelligence et
l'habileté pour comprendre il est dans
un âne éléments il a fait exprès nous
venons l'habileté de comprendre qu'il
est dans un environnement très différent
où l'art oratoire bien sûr a son
importance mais avec des codes très
différent et je crois qu'il a envie il
nous l'a dit ce matin après midi mais je
crois qu'il a envie d'apprendre ces
codes de faire honneur au parlement et
c'est aussi pour ça qu'il perd jacquemin
jeu
l'aja c'est l'analyse sur dupond-moretti
d'autant que souvenez vous hier au
moment de l'entrée au conseil des
ministres c'est un des seuls à passer
trop tarder justement sur le perron de
l'elysée où il y avait tous ces
journalistes qui photographier l'arrivée
avec effectivement tous les journalistes
attendent et dupond moretti il ne s'est
pas arrêtée il a traversé les marches et
je pense qu'effectivement il a compris
qu'il y avait une attente chez lui une
attente sans doute de d'hommes forts
avec une voix qui parle fort et que on a
vu chez lui il a pris le contre pied
absolu oui c'est vrai il va être un peu
l'esprit qui posait même des questions
au président de l'assemblée nationale et
qui pour lui demander combien de temps
il avait dit que c'était des comptes et
du moment où il été chahuté et moi je
moi je trouve que ce sont des moments
qui sont quand même intéressant dans
l'hémicycle où tous les tellement figés
organisé prévu à l'avance les ministres
il émane mais je pense qu'il ya aussi
effectivement c'est un homme malin et
que on va voir dans les manières depuis
par ailleurs on l'a dit tout à l'heure
le discours de politique générale mais
n'ayant pas encore eu lieu il n'est pas
encore en capacité de défendre aussi une
politique même si on l'a aussi vu du
côté de la passation de pouvoir il ya
une feuille de route en tout cas qui
visiblement lui a été fixé en tout cas
qui s'est approprié je sais pas s'il est
exactement bien des sujets de la réforme
du parquet c'est plutôt intéressant mais
il a aussi dit je fais confiance à un
homme qui s'appelle emmanuel macron donc
il a aussi endossé les habits de l'homme
qui est rangé derrière un autre homme
qui à emmanuel macron et on l'a aussi vu
cet après midi l'assemblée romareda au
sénat on a vu tout de suite que des
sénateurs puisqu'elle est aussi des
questions au sénat ne l'ont pas ratée en
le mettant dans ses contradictions en
lui parlant dieu du retour des
djihadistes il est favorable au retour
des jihadistes français ça ne sera pas
possible parce que ce n'est pas la ligne
du gouvernement veut y jouer là dessus
deux choses d'abord il y à ici à
l'assemblée nationale une magnifique
bibliothèque où il y a deux siècles de
débats retranscrits et où on peut voir
que même au 19e siècle il y avait des
invectives
il y avait des chahuts et que ça fait
partie de la vie parlementaire et que ça
fait partie effectivement de
l'expression des convictions et de la
représentation nationale
aujourd'hui eric dupond-moretti il
faudra qu'il le sache il a un grand
avantage c'est qu'il a un micro et qui
on entend d'abord ce qui est dit dans le
micro plus tôt ce qui est dit au tour
donc il pourra continuer son propos sans
se laisser déborder par par les chu
quant à la question vous vous posez
effectivement
eric dupond moretti a dit et redit qu'il
était un homme libre
or il va falloir qu'ils comprennent
aujourd'hui qu'il est aussi un porte
parole de la solidarité gouvernementale
et qu'il va falloir avant tout porter la
parole du président de la république et
du premier ministre
raison pour laquelle teddy music man qui
me serait jamais prouvé jamais mines est
ce que la justice devrait maintenir le
quand même je voudrais mettre en lien
quand même s'il y avait une interview de
jean castex matin où il a parlé de la
justice et où il a parlé de redonner les
moyens
donc j'imagine une traduction budgétaire
et je me dis que dans les échanges sur
le portefeuille sur la nomination est
sur la feuille de route il a eu cet
échange entre du 2e au 10e rang
protocolaire dans gouvernement c'est
quand même un super l'ancien ministre
madame madame ont déjà oublié son qu'il
s'agit d'un bel ou b était au deuxième
rang protocolaire du témoin le dire j'y
tiens parce que je tiens au monde
judiciaire et la justice je compte sur
lui pour batailler pas seulement en
hémicycle absolument partout et obtenir
des budgets pour la justice rappelle que
vous êtes à la commission des lois vous
êtes juriste et puis bon c'est le numéro
deux du gouvernement c'est pas elle
couvre en chine le sans faute de ces
questions gouvernement regarder au total
ces cinq milliards d'euros qui sont déjà
mobilisés bien entendu nous allons
continuer nous allons continuer à
travers le troisième projet de finance
de loi de finances rectificative et pour
le secteur culturel
c'est 1,06 milliard d'euros qui seront
mobilisés des dépenses fiscales des
exonérations sociales et bien sûr des
crédits budgétaires à la romareda une
ministre populaire de la culture déjà
dans les dossiers techniques précises
c'est un peu dur quand même pour la
droite non oui en même temps c'est la
reconnaissance d'un message que l'on
porte depuis trois ans et que ce
gouvernement manquait cruellement
d'expérience cette majorité manquait
cruellement de visage pour incarner
quelque chose et notamment le sens de
l'état qui était bien pauvrement
abandonner ces dernières années roselyne
bachelot a l'expérience racines basques
auront la vue est très à l'aise dans la
vie parlementaire
elle est un visage de ce casting mais
elle masque aussi une grande rigidité du
remaniement parce qu'en fin de compte le
gouvernement reste en place
sa large partie des ministres donc est
ce que roselyne bachelot sera imposé
cette expérience et ce sens de l'état à
l'ensemble de ses collègues du
gouvernement aux nouvelles en tout cas
ça fait quand même pas mal de prises à
droite que bachelot castex sans compter
les ministres de droite les poids lourds
qui se voit renforcée bonsoir géraldine
woessner vous suivez la politique au
point chroniqueuse dans cette émission
alors est-ce que la droitisation du
gouvernement au fond est à l'image du
pays est exactement parce que c'est vrai
qu emmanuel macron a pas réussi à faire
entrer deux personnalités de centre
gauche et c'est pas faute d'avoir essayé
dans ce gouvernement mais il n'a pas non
plus ouvert la porte à la droite pure on
avait parlé de guillaume larrivé à la
justice ça aurait envoyé un tout autre
message signale que ces personnalités de
centre droit qui a cardin un gaullisme
social le maire d'un manager jean castex
bon en cela oui macro colle à la réalité
du pays parce qu il faut lire les
enquêtes successives du cevipof le
centre de recherches politiques de
sciences po
toutes les dernières le montre seulement
30% des français se définissent eux
mêmes comme proche d'un parti de gauche
lvps france insoumise 30%
donc c'est le centre de gravité du pays
qui s'est déclarée placé au centre droit
et avec ce remaniement macumba consolide
simplement cet ancrage ce qui complique
d'ailleurs à l'avis des républicains qui
vont devoir clarifier leurs stratégies
s'ils veulent garder un espace être que
est ce que finalement je vais vous
donner la parole même je fais une petite
relance à géraldine est ce qu'il
n'aurait pas dû prendre en compte
davantage la vague verte à votre avis
géraldine et la question écologique s'il
colle à la société mais quelle vague
miriama les verts ont engrangé des
succès c'est vrai ça parle aux
journalistes au spécialiste de la vie
politique parce que on voit un nouveau
parti qui dira la locomotive de la
gauche au détriment du du ps qui se
casse la figure
mais si on prend du champ les verts
aujourd'hui il dirige trop
civile sur l'ensemble du territoire
seulement douze villes de plus de 20
mille habitants sur un total de 454
quand même donc parler de vague
c'est excessif et en revanche on peut en
parler et de déferlante même concernant
l'abstention 58 4 % des français ne sont
pas allés voter à ces municipales et
c'est peut-être à eux justement que le
président s'adresse en nommant une
personnalité aussi hors champ
spectaculaire et populaire que quelqu'un
eric dupond moretti
vous savez dans ces enquêtes d'opinion
toujours quand on demande aux français
ce que leur évoque la politique les mots
qui reviennent le plus ces méfiances et
d'égout est ce qu'une partie de cet
électorat qui était curé de la politique
pour être captées par des gens qui ont
l'air un peu devenir d'une autre
dimension c'est un pari il est risqué
uniquement si les actes ne suivent pas
les fed annonce évidemment merci merci
beaucoup géraldine coralie dubost au
fond ce gouvernement suit une
droitisation du pays un centre de
gravité plus à droite c'est pas nouveau
mais aussi avec des personnalités plus
populaires j'ai lu dans le monde
aujourd'hui un stratège de l'elysée qui
expliquait que ce gouvernement celui de
la cause du peuple moretti bachelot pour
ce sera menée à la au territoire sera
menée en france audit du bas qui aurait
pu porter un gilet jaune est ce qu'ils
vont voir ça aussi et plusieurs choses
qui ont été dites sur le l'aspect
gouvernements de droite ou absence de
gens de gauche
moi je trouve que la lecture est biaisé
si vous regardez les postes ministériels
qui sont charnières dans le cadre de la
relance vous avez des gens de gauche ou
des marcheurs donc on est sûr de la ra
charland marc lemaire qui est quand même
un marcheur historique est avec nous
depuis le départ vous prenez barbara
pompe lui c'est quand même la foule sur
le centre gauche champcueil colo non
mais vous pouvez contester le ballon
jouant très très vite les puces arm
qu'est la gaucherie donc c'est ce que je
vous dis je vous dis vous êtes sur des
marcheurs historiques qui sont plutôt de
centre gauche c'est exactement ce que je
vous dis sûr c'est sur ces postes
ministériels clés dans le cadre de la
relance mon la santé on va peut-être pas
dire
c'est la droite n'ont plus faim mais y
en a plusieurs mais pardon mais c'est
pas comme ça qu'on va faire un voyage
vous aurais adoré le temps dredd fait
pas de répondre donc il est vrai - il
est plus à gauche qu'il y paraît ce
gouvernement cesari je pense qu'il faut
pas avoir une lecture biaisée je le
trouve au contraire très équilibré et
audacieux audacieux et là je rebondis
sur ce que votre question sur finalement
ce ministre très populaire qui sont
capables d'incarner de s'adresser à tout
le monde y compris ceux qui ne vont pas
voter
et là dessus je vaux je vous rejoins moi
ça me préoccupe énormément alors c'est
dit vous avez chacun 15 secondes pour
ton est clair moi je crois que la
tiédeur ne fait pas une politique on l'a
vu depuis trois ans emmanuel macron n'a
pas réussi à emporter l'adhésion des
français parce qu'on ne sait pas quelles
sont foncés conviction et faire un
patchwork de ministres venus de la
gauche venu de la droite venus de la
société civile ça ne fait pas une
politique et je crois que les français
auront besoin à un moment de revenir à
une ligne politique claire avec un
président de la république premier
ministre un gouvernement qui sauront sur
une ligne politique claire et ferme la
coloration j'ai presque je pense
précisément qui mène une macro on se
contrefout de l'idée d'avoir des grandes
figures de gauche son gouvernement parce
qu'il assume totalement d'avoir une
ligne politique et une ligne à droite là
où échouera
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est plus
inquiétant c'est d'avoir effectivement
de mire misc comme le german un
intérieur qui marquent quand même un
penchant de droit on atteint camp d'en
face et s'est clairement la synthèse
entre sarkozy et les maquereaux vous
restez avec nous parce qu'on va regarder
maintenant le palmarès des députés
thomas des prêts leur a demandé au fonds
de noter leurs prestations dans
l'hémicycle ça thomas n'est ce pas oui
exactement myriam et pour cette première
séance de questions au gouvernement les
nouveaux ministres se sont fait un petit
peu chahuté par les députés
mais comment s'en sont-ils sortis je
vous raconte
alors vous savez c'est un petit peu la
période des conseils de classe dans les
écoles en ce moment alors nous aussi on
a demandé aux députés de noter les
nouveaux ministres qui sont les bons
élèves qui doit progresser qui a encore
de la marge
regardez quelle note vous mettiez pour
la première intervention du nouveau
ministre de la justice eric dupond
moretti
peut mieux faire concernant le potentiel
de l'élève je lui mettrais qu'un 3 sur
10 pour la première intervention je lui
mettrais 3
pourquoi parce qu'il a confondu le
prétoire et l'assemblée nationale qu'il
a un talent oratoire mieux faire qu'ils
sachent que ces deux minutes et pas plus
moi j'aimais 5 parce que la forme
n'était pas très convaincante pour une
première un peu fébrile et malhabile on
est à 2 3 sur 10 c'était quand même pas
ce qu'il a raconté n'avaient pas
beaucoup de sens 10 sur 10 parce que je
pense que le ministre dupont moretti
porte quelque chose et que dans cette
république on a besoin de donner du sens
barbara pompili sur disque elle note
voulu mais terrier je pense qu'on a
touché le fond c'était absolument
affligeant barbara pompili c'était le
degré zéro donc on sera proche de zéro
au moins huit sur dix d'abord c'est une
femme suit elle a très bien répondu ce
matin et nous savons d'ores et déjà que
nous allons pouvoir travailler avec 4
sur 10 complètement hors sujet il ya des
enjeux climatiques qui sont extrêmement
importants le propos n'était pas de
remercier tous ceux avec qui elles
avaient ou allaient travailler a dit ça
mon amie barbara et surtout bon bah je
serai là pour te soutenir roselyne
bachelot votre ancien camarade de l'ump
des républicains auxquels notre pour la
ministre la culture un bon 8
voilà là aussi ça fait des formations
profs mais elle a du métier on sent
qu'elle est à l'aise
elle est venue très préparée avec force
détails donc je lui mettrais un bon 6 et
demi sur 10 même si c'était un peu
biaisé genedis
10h10 la mer notre c'est la meilleure de
la we cannot pour jean castex prémices
mais non c'est une catastrophe
c'est dire si c'est comme ça à chaque
usager on va s'endormir on va trouver ça
très l'on peut mieux faire
a besoin de sortir de sa coquille de
s'épanouir
c'était un peu lent ce matin un peu
poussif alors peut-être qu'il va devoir
apprendre un peu être plus concis dans
ses propos mais moi j'ai trouvé plutôt
très bien le 6 peut tomber à 4 ou peut
monter à 7 ou 8
malheureusement ils passent en
comparaison après un effort philippe qui
était remarquable dans l'exercice même
si sur le fond je critiquais voilà bien
au rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour
la deuxième séance de questions au
gouvernement du nouveau gouvernement
castex d'ici là les nouveaux ministres
seront un peu plus rodés et nous on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler dans ma journée
à l'assemblée lé merci beaucoup thomas
il reste une poignée de secondes voulait
noter vous lui donnez combien rouge en
moins cher mais les félicitations pour
ce lancement et les encouragements for
less sud fo barreda c'est un
gouvernement moyens donc je mets la
moyenne je vais être très sévère le
premier ministre je crois n'a pas fait
une grande démonstration et sur le fond
et sur la forme ou que je suis assez
d'accord avec le 3 qui semblait faire
oui
le consensus est facile de parler après
edouard philippe merci infiniment de
vous être prêté à ce petit jeu des notes
en des questions des premières questions
au gouvernement
on va parler à présent du prix du livre
politique 2020 et son lauréat rice qui
nous a accordé un entretien mais d'abord
savez vous que chaque année à
l'assemblée et un jury députés et
journalistes qui décerne ce prix
désormais bien installé des essais
fiction et même bande dessinée le prix
comprend différentes catégories comme
nous l'expliquent ahmed tazir c'est le
prix littéraire à l'assemblée nationale
dans ce haut lieu de la démocratie qu'on
fréquente et des écrivains députés aussi
universel que lamartine victor hugo
léopold sédar senghor aimé césaire le
prix du livre politique
on pense un ouvrage de la politique paru
dans l'année écoulée il existe depuis
près de 30 ans les lauréats sont pour la
plupart des journalistes mais pas
seulement comme laurent fabius qui
obtient le prix en 96 pour son
autobiographie les blessures de la
vérité fadela amara en 2004 pour ni
ni soumises ou encore frédéric
mitterrand dix ans plus tard pour la
récréation chronique sur son mandat de
ministre de la culture pour l'édition
2001 le prix a été décerné à risque pour
son livre une minute 49 secondes le
directeur de charlie hebdo livre son
récit sur l'attentât du 7 janvier 2015
olemps même 7 janvier une de mes
craintes c'est l oubli
c'était ce qu'on oublie inexorablement
ce qui périrent ce jour-là il y a le
prix du livre politique
il y a aussi les autres ariane chemin
grand reporter au monde obtient le prix
étudiant de la bd politique avec benalla
et moi l'histoire du prince et du
conseiller en fait c'est pas parce que
la bd à des cases et des montres des
grimaces et c'est vrai que c'est pas
sérieux celle inverse
mais là il est drôle et c'est un
personnage drôle amusant qui d'ailleurs
faisait beaucoup rire emmanuel macron
mais c'est pas pour ça que cette
histoire n'est pas très sérieuse et très
grave en plus de macron oui en fait ça
raconte les coulisses du pouvoir à
travers l'histoire d'un conseiller à
l'exemple d'alain on raconte ce que
c'est que l'avis de l'elysée est le rôle
des conseillers les messes basses les
petits conseils la communication de
crise
cinq rencontres a permis d'apprendre
dessinée david djaïz c'est le petit
jeune qui monte qui monte à peine 30 ans
inspecteur des finances et prix étudiant
du livre politique pour ce lot
démocratie un essai sur la nation trop
importante selon lui pour la laisser à
l'extrême droite pour signer ira être
comme studio disait l'intellectuel
tacite sans colère et avec application
et je crois que c'est vraiment ce dont
nous avons besoin aujourd'hui pour
réparer le commun et y voilà pour le
casting 2020
allez rendez vous l'année prochaine pour
découvrir les nouveaux talents du livre
politique
bonsoir rice gens et bravo félicitations
vous êtes le lauréat 2020 du prix du
livre politique pour ce livre une minute
49 secondes chez actes sud livre dans
lequel vous revenez sur cette journée du
7 janvier mais pas seulement 7 janvier
2015 d'attentats de charlie hebdo
comment vous réagissez à ce prix
l'écrivain le dessinateur le patron de
charlie hebdo est ce que ça fait plaisir
est ce qu'on s'y attend à avoir un prix
du livre politique
non parce que c'est le premier livre que
j'écris donc je n'ai pas la prétention
d'être un écrivain c'est le lieu d'un
livre écrit un peu par un novice quoi
donc je ne pensais pas enfin je pensais
pas faire des prix ou des choses comme
ça va déjà que le livre existe deux
s'étaient déjà pas mal éjecté le livre
existe oui il fallait il fallait
l'écrire absolument pas c'était début
c'est difficile d'écrire un livre
là-dessus et donc que le livre existe
qu'ils soient diffusés lu par beaucoup
de lecteurs c'est déjà beaucoup
et si en plus ça il est récompensés ou
reconnus comme ayant une valeur
voilà un intérêt comme ce prix le semble
l'indiquer mais c'est un prix du livre
politique c'est aussi un acte politique
de de donner un prix à un livre comme
celui là qui raconte la violence le
terrorisme qui raconte minute par minute
on va y venir ce qui s'est passé ce que
vous avez vécu et comment on reste
vivant après ça vous le prenez comme tel
c'est à dire que c'est une question qui
s'est posée quand j'ai voulu commencer à
écrire jeu j'étais un peu écartelée
entre faire un récit personnel et faire
un récit politique parce que je voulais
pas qu'on oublie la dimension politique
de ce qui s'est passé le 7 janvier est
aussi le 8 et le 9 faut pas oublier les
autres attentats qui ont eu durant ces
jours
ces attentats contre les policiers puis
les parcs à chiens et donc pour la
dimension politique a été capital donc
c'est vrai que le fait de recevoir le
prix du livre politique
c'est indique qu'au moins la dimension
politique que je voulais
ce que je voulais présent dans le livre
a été bien bien compris ce qui est
important pour moi
et pourtant vous écrivez c'est la
première phrase de votre livre il est
impossible d'écrire quoi que ce soit oui
parce qu'en fait il faut tout de suite
je pense aussi être consciente de ses
limites en tant que rédacteur ou en tant
que témoin et aussi pour le lecteur faut
pas faire croire aux lecteurs qu'on
arrivera à tout lui transmettre j'ai
essayé de transmettre ce que j'ai pu
le maximum que j'ai pu mais je me dis
qu'il ya toujours des choses que
j'arriverai peut-être pas à communiquer
via de l'indicible
oui le vouloir écrire là dessus c'est se
confronter aussi a ses limites
on voit aussi ce qu'on peut faire ce
qu'on peut dire est ce qu'on n'arrive
pas à dire 'oui' ou qu'on n'arrivera
peut-être jamais à faire passer il ya
des émotions qui sont difficilement
transmissible on va dire lesquelles par
exemple le fait de ce fait d'être
confronté à sa propre perdition son
propre anéantissement
c'est plus quelque chose de théorique
même si on sait tous qu'un jour on
mourra le canton il réellement
confrontés à ça on n'en sort pas intact
et on garde en mémoire sa pour toujours
la perception de la vie plus du tout la
même
elle avait change à jamais c'est sûr
voilà sur elle ressemble à quoi la vie
aujourd'hui elle est elle est là
on est toujours vivant mais il faut
qu'on vit avec ce qui nous reste de vie
une partie de sa vie qui a disparu qui a
été anéantie y est voilà donc si vous
écrivez un rescapé comme un chêne touché
par la foudre à moitié vivent à moitié
mort c'est un livre sur cette question
là qu'est ce que ça veut dire de
survivre après ça ben oui c'est ce que
vous dites sur que on prend conscience
qu enfin c'est comme une sorte d'
accélération de son propre délitement
c'est à dire que quand on vieillit bien
peu à peu on perd ses facultés et on va
vers la fin là c'est un accélérateur de
faim c'est à dire qu'on a l'impression
de d'être presque de devenir un
vieillard en quelques jours
quasiment bonne partie de votre vie
disparaît des instants quelle vision
vous avez aujourd'hui sept minutes 49
puisque vous n'arrivez pas à la décrire
précisément vous préférez coûté les
secondes au moment où les frères kwasi
arrive dans la rédaction de charlie
hebdo dans le 11e arrondissement vous
comptez seconde après seconde
et à la fin vous écrivez je suis vivant
je ne suis pas mort bah oui c'est à dire
que vous n'êtes plus maître de votre
existence et
la seule chose que vous pouvez faire
c'est attendre attendre ce qu'on a
décidé de vous voilà votre sort dépend
de la volonté de ces individus et vous
êtes suspendu et vous attendez vous
attendez la dernière seconde et les
temps tu as fait minime en longe imagine
c'est long et en même temps gamberge
aussi je pense à plein de choses je me
disais j'étais bien conscient que ce qui
était en train de se passer était
quelque chose d'énorme et je me disais
je sais pas si je sortirai de vivante de
tout ça mais ça va avoir des
conséquences énormes donc alterner entre
l' angoisse du moment du dernier moment
qui va arriver et peut-être aussi qu'est
ce qui arrivera après tout ça voilà on
pense déjà après tout ça quand on vit ce
beaucoup on pense quand on pense à plein
de choses ça il ya cette couverture est
très belle racontez nous cette feuille
de quel oeil s'agit-il précisément c'est
un oeil à faux les terrifier même qu'à
peur c'est un détail d'un tableau que
j'aime beaucoup que je décris d'ailleurs
dans le livre c'est le chasseur à cheval
de jéricho qui est au louvre et jeu
quand vous regardez le grand tableau
comme ça vous êtes parfois très
impressionné par la vue d'ensemble il ya
souvent des détails sur des détails qui
sont frappants et c'est times avait
toujours marqué parce qu'on avait
l'impression que ce que ce cheval et est
possédé par la folie
qu'ils avaient vu des choses qu'il
n'aurait jamais dû voir et finalement
l'oeil c'est aussi l'avis du dessinateur
c'est à dire que ce jour là j'ai vu des
choses où j'aurais pu voir des choses
que j'aurais jamais dû voir alors que
pourtant le métier d'un dessinateur
c'est de regarder tout ce qui est autour
de soi disant parler de la folie dans le
livre elles vont toujours cette peur de
devenir fou de basculer dans la folie
aujourd'hui peut-être moins qu'à une
époque mais on perçoit la fragilité de
ce qu'on est
quand on est confronté à des choses
comme ça on voit autour de soi des gens
qui ont été fracturées qui mentalement
et et oui c'est vrai que des fois qu'on
peut se poser la question de savoir si
c'est pas le début d'un chemin qui peut
vous mais à la folie si vous souvenir
c'est pas les pieds sur terre et après
la tuerie dans l'engagement pour charlie
il était évident de continuer vous êtes
aujourd'hui le patron de ce journal
satirique
il fallait continuer coûte que coûte il
a été renforcé au contraire souviens
juste après ça a été terrible
vous avez envie de tout lâcher c'est des
questions qu'on se pose d'un rien est
évident au lendemain de tout ça parce
que physiquement j'étais comme les
blessés va on était au fond du trou je
savais pas si physiquement je serai
capable de faire encore des choses dans
un mois dans deux mois je savais pas si
j'étais capable encore de dessiner je
n'ai aucune idée de ce que je serai aux
sorties sorties de tout ça mais d'un
autre côté je me disais que on se
retrouvait dans une situation politique
ou un journal dans une démocratie avait
été quasiment anéantie par une
organisation terroriste et je me dis on
peut pas on peut pas laisser ça se
réalise et donc malgré les menaces de
mort malgré les gardes du corps qui sont
tous les jours encore aujourd'hui avec
vous certes signé c'est pas qu'on
continue c'est que si vous croyez un
minimum ce à quoi vous croyez vous
n'avez pas le choix il faut faire ça les
circonstances nous impose de continuer
c'est pâques un choix personnel pour se
faire plaisir confortable inconfortable
vous êtes dans un moment politique et ce
moment politique vais pas choisi d'être
d'être au coeur de ce moment il faut
prendre les décisions à la hauteur de ce
moment ses valeurs auxquelles il croit
charlie hebdo c'est combat que vous avez
décidé de continuer à mener
vous les trouvez dans quel état la
question de la caricature de la liberté
d'expression dans un pays démocratique
comme la france la question de la
laïcité de l'irrévérence elles vont bien
ces valeurs là ou pas moi je veux pas
sombrer dans le pessimisme j'ai plutôt
tendance à être optimiste je pense quand
même qu'il ya des messages qui sont
passés j'espère je crois aujourd'hui que
plus personne ne remet en cause
sérieusement le droit à la caricature
c'est là peut-être consolidé je sais pas
mais après faut le faire vivre
il suce pas de défendre des grandes
libertés les grands principes toute la
difficulté c'est de faire vivre la
liberté d'expression c'est de continuer
aussi de s'exprimer de prendre des
risques et ça c'est le rôle c'est la
responsabilité de tout le monde
il n'y a pas que charlie hebdo qui a le
droit de s'exprimer tout le monde a le
droit de s'exprimer et de défendre des
idées et des convictions donc tout ce
qu'on veut c'est donner envie à tous les
citoyens de s'approprier ces libertés de
les faire vivre
est-ce qu'ils sont aussi audacieux les
jeunes journaliste de charlie hebdo
qu'il s'engage lourde aujourd'hui dans
cet hebdomadaire satirique est ce qu'ils
sont les futurs charb cabu wolinski
aussi irrévérencieux que ceux qui ont
été exécutés par les frères kwasi je
pense que s'ils sont là c'est pas par
hasard et qui savent aussi très bien ce
que c'est que charlie hebdo
ce sont eux qui sont venus au journal
donc ils veulent faire ce journal donc
j'ai confiance dans leur détermination
alors depuis cinq ans depuis les
attentats le monde a beaucoup changé
forcément il ya trump bessonart au
johnson maquereau au pouvoir l'émergence
du mouvement mitu la crise du code vide
qui a tout écrasé et maintenant les
blacks
yves matters c'est des sujets
inflammables on peut en parler
tranquillement librement dans charlie
aujourd'hui on peut dire ce qu'on veut
la question c'est de savoir quoi dire
mais c'est une question qu'on se pose
pour tous les sujets sains charlie quoi
dire d'original parce que c'est si c'est
pour répéter ce que tout le monde dit
mais c'est vrai que c'était mais vous
vous sentez toujours aussi les bras
malgré ce qui s'est passé mais oui au
contraire ça nous a peut-être confiante
et encore plus dans notre confiance dans
le droit de dire ce qu'on a envie de
dire si on se mettait à douter de cette
liberté là non c'était pas la peine de
continuer et voulait mais notre époque
aujourd'hui il ya tu signes at-il une
époque qu'on aurait aimé une autre
époque on aurait aimé je ne sais pas
elle s'impose à nous il faut c'est à
nous de la faire vivre mais quelle ça
voilà il ya un climat particulier où la
violence peut jaillir à tout moment les
réseaux sociaux créé de la tension mais
il faut pas suivi c'est parce que
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait rêver avec un
journal comme chalet il faut pas se
laisser impressionner
parce que c'est vrai qu'on est aussi
dans les réseaux sociaux dans dans
l'intimidation dans l'imprécation dans
la dans la diffamation dans la jurdant
dans la menace tout ça c'est des percées
des jeux des rapports de force mais
quand on a la chance de pouvoir
s'exprimer dans un journal il faut
surtout pas soumettre sa liberté à la
peur de choquer les uns les autres sinon
c'est quand même faut pas faire un
journal ne faut pas travailler un média
après charles et après les attentats
pardon il ya eu des millions de lecteurs
un million de lecteurs supplémentaires
je le vois on est aujourd'hui
toute la presse est frappé par la crise
économique et charlie charlie se portent
pas trop mal même on a un lectorat qui a
ses fidèles
voilà à peu près trente mille lecteurs
en kiosque et 30 mille abonnés à peu
près donc c'est des chiffres qui sont
peu près stable voilà mais c'est vrai
que bon rien n'est acquis il faut
toujours faire un journal qui donne au
lecteur envie de le racheter la semaine
suivante voilà c'est ça faire un journal
pour revenir au livre vous êtes
dessinateur c'est votre premier c'est
votre premier livre vous auriez pu
représenter dans un dessein ce qui s'est
passé l'horreur non parce que je pense
que l'écrit sastre une espèce de
distance c'est la bonne distance voilà
au dire des choses peut-être même plus
précisément mais sans forcément les
représenter il faut laisser au lecteur
peut pas dire les libertés de l'imaginer
mais il faut que ça reste quand même un
peu j'ai d'ailleurs brumeux ça sert à
rien de donner des détails en fait trop
de détails
je ne suis pas sûr que cette forcément à
comprendre peut-être consignes on s'est
peut-être sombrer dans le voyeurisme
c'est aussi peut-être distraire un peu
le lecteur avec des choses qui n'aide
pas forcément à comprendre le sens de
cet événement en fait comment il a été
accueilli
ça fait plusieurs mois maintenant qu'il
est sorti en librairie vous avez
rencontré les lecteurs comment ça s'est
passé ce contact
bah ça s'est plutôt bien passé
je pense qu'il a été plutôt bien
accueilli font tous les cas moi plutôt
réservé un accueil au challenge est ce
que vous dites qu'il ya de
l'impossibilité même dans les mots est
ce que dans un dialogue après avoir lu
le livre avec vos lecteurs
on comprend d'autres choses on arrive
enfin je n'espérai parvenu à faire
passer quand même certaines choses a qu
à qui vous vous adressez pour qui avez
vous écrit se lire à qui vous pensiez
quand vous écriviez ce livre je pense je
me disais il ya que les écrits qui
restent les dialogues la parole ça
s'oublie
donc je me dis tant que rien n'est écrit
le danger c'est l'oubli donc un écrit ça
reste donc je voulais qu'ils ont une
trace après je sais pas ce que les gens
en feront c'est un livre de combat un
livre de conte la colère aussi c'est un
témoignage et c'est avant tout un
témoignage contre l'oubli
cinq ans après merci beaucoup merci
infiniment reese une minute 49 secondes
c'est chez actes sud
c'est encore dans les très bonnes les
paris et c'est le prix 2020 du livre
politique
merci à vous et merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis très belle soirée sur lcp
à demain
[Musique]